to my 1 million fans thank you alright
hello everybody this is Martin wire here
one year five months and four days
that's how long this channel has been
around and in that time I've managed to
make about one thousand three hundred
and sixty-one videos and since I started
not a day has gone by that I am NOT
eternally grateful for what you have
done to change my life people often tell
me that my videos have helped them
through dark times but the opposite is
true too you guys have managed to push
me past one of the worst parts of my
life and given me opportunities to
travel and meet and work with some
amazingly talented people who I wouldn't
be here without but this milestone isn't
about me it's about you there is nothing
that I can say or do to thank you enough
I believe that we can change the world
and you guys stand a million strong
behind that belief there is no limit to
what we can do together so as we move
into the future and as we set new goals
and blow them completely out of the
water I want you guys to know that I am
never going to change I've already
caught myself once and I will never make
that mistake again
so thank you for everything that you've
done for me and everything you've done
to help better the world well thank you
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye